c'est une réalité méconnue du grand
public les bouts d'épuration de
certaines municipalités sont employées
comme engrais dans les champs mais si le
pouvoir fertilisant de ses matières ne
fait aucun doute leur utilisation
suscite tout de même beaucoup de
questions
[Applaudissements]
un adulte élimine en moyenne 200 g
d'excrément et un litre d'urine par jour
à l'échelle du Québec cela équivaut à 70
000 tonnes rejetés par semaine de quoi
remplir 29 piscines olympiques
[Musique]
des champs agricoles
j'ai laissé tomber mon fumier de poule
pour aller là dessus puis là je suis
vraiment très très content ça fait un
job de solide avec un produit comme ça
souvent sur aller chercher un peu de
tout et capable de prendre le carence
santé humain est utilisé depuis des
millénaires pour la fertilisation des
sols en raison de sa teneur en phosphore
azote potassium carbone
urée et matières organiques mais nous
rejetons aussi des produits chimiques
pharmaceutiques cosmétiques
microplastiques etc est-ce vraiment sans
danger dépendre des bouts dans des
champs
de concentration de quelque chose de
toxique ou de quelque chose qui pourrait
s'accumuler et devenir un problème dans
les champs et l'école
[Musique]
avant l'épandage au champ au tout début
du cycle les matières résiduelles sont
traitées dans une station d'épuration
comme ici à Saint-Hyacinthe l'eau
usée qu'on reçoit à l'usine après avoir
été enlevé des patiaires solides les
grossières enlever de son sable mais
décanteurs primaires où on va avoir un
long temps de séjour pour laisser les
particules solides décantées au fond du
décanteur
l'autre était est rejeté dans la rivière
yamasca et les matières solides sont
traitées biologiquement dans des grandes
cuves appelées biodigesteurs
municipal qu'on mélange qu'on alimente
en même temps par exemple que les
résidus des entreprises agroalimentaires
et en plus du lactosérum qui est d'un
autre produit qu'on reçoit
ça va être par exemple des yogourts en
contenant
[Musique]
dans les digestors c'est vraiment comme
dans un estomac la matière organique va
être digérée ce processus de
biomécanisation génère du biogaz et des
bouts aussi appelés biosolides ou
digestif
[Musique]
c'est la dernière étape c'est le
résultat c'est vraiment le gâteau qu'on
obtient c'est notre bout des hydraté
qu'on va envoyer au champ 100% des bouts
d'épuration de la Ville de
Saint-Hyacinthe sont détournés de
l'enfouissement vers l'épandage agricole
soit 25000 tonnes par année cette
valorisation permet aux villes de
diminuer les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et de faire des économies
en 2008 nous dépensions pour moins de 1
million 200000 dollars pour disposer de
nouveaux à l'enfouissement aujourd'hui
on a une dépense de 200 000 dollars par
année une économie donc considérable
c'est bout des plus rations municipales
ou industrielles sont utilisés par des
milliers d'agriculteurs au Québec sur
environ 1% des terres agricoles de la
province elles doivent être répandues
sur des cultures destinées à
l'alimentation animale
[Musique]
et si je cultive principalement du blé
du soya et du maïs cette année j'ai reçu
aux alentours de 28300 tonnes debout de
faire recouvrir à peu près 20 secondes
25 30 hectares
je les ai peint après la récolte de blé
donc vers la fin ou début septembre j'ai
réussi étendre ça en fin de semaine en
bonne partie
puis après ça mes engrais verts ont
capté toutes les éléments cortisants
d'apporter par le
digestat et les entreposés dans dans ses
racines dans ses feuilles et les
relâcher au printemps suivants parce que
la plante va mourir pendant l'hiver pour
du froid en plus des bouts d'épuration
plusieurs résidus sont utilisés pour
enrichir les sols les bouts de papetière
agroalimentaires d'abattoirs des cendres
etc
[Musique]
jacoger et pend des résidus papetier
depuis trois ans
de la rue puis ici nous on a deux sortes
de bout on a une bouche aux langues on a
une bouffe artisanes
il apporte beaucoup de matière organique
ça va aider à nourrir notre sol ça va
l'enrichir la matière organique c'est un
produit qui va aider à conserver
l'humidité dans le sol entre autres
choses ce qui va aider à avoir une
meilleure teneur en eau ainsi aider les
plantes dans leur croissance
les 3700 tonnes de boue que Monsieur
Auger est peint sur 78 hectares lui
fournissent un rendement identique à ce
qu'il obtenait en dépendant du fumier
mais le gain est clairement économique
non
parce que tous nos fumiers sont très
loin ça coûte très cher faire descendre
notre fumée ici c'est environ 15 à 20
000 dollars par année l'avantage des
bouts c'est livré gratuitement au chant
on a juste les pandage on économie sur
le coup de transport sur le coup
dépendage de chaud sur le coup
d'épandage d'engrais c'est quand même
montant assez important surtout avec les
hausses du prix des engrais
ce sont des entreprises privées qui
gèrent ou et comment les bouts seront
livrées elle paye même parfois les
agriculteurs pour les recevoir au Québec
englobe et vERIDIS sont les principaux
acteurs ils sont engagés par une
municipalité ou une industrie en général
ce sont les agronomes de ces entreprises
qui sollic directement les agriculteurs
notre bassin de clientèle est au-dessus
de 1000 agriculteurs pratiquement toutes
les régions du Québec on fait la gestion
annuellement dans la proximativement là
250.000 tonnes qui peuvent aller en
valorisation agricole
cette valorisation est encadrée par le
ministère de l'Environnement son
objectif est avant tout de détourner les
bouts de l'enfouissement pour éviter des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre majeur
donc il ne compile pas le nombre de
fermes qui en épingle mais seulement le
volume de boue est pendu on compte un
total de 842 stations de traitement des
eaux à travers le Québec qui ont
vraiment des profils de traitement très
différents sur ces 842 on en a 90 en
2018 qui sont allés valoriser leur
biosoline en épandage agricole
nous notre volonté est évidemment
d'augmenter les volumes qui seront
valorisés
le ministère de l'Environnement encadre
la qualité de la matière qui peut être
épendue ça c'est à travers le guide des
matières résiduelles fertilisantes et
elle va aussi encadrer l'activité
elle-même dépendage par rapport sur quel
type de culture les distances etc les
contraintes principales c'est des
distances séparatrices des cours d'eau
les fossés les maisons voisines les
puits d'eau potable on essaie de placer
des drapeaux sur les bords de chêne les
près des cours d'eau ces choses là pour
être certain que les camionneurs ils
savent exactement dans quel cas ils
doivent livrer
si les règles d'épandage du ministère ne
sont pas respectées il y a des risques
de contaminer l'environnement quant à la
qualité des boues elle doit être évaluée
selon quatre critères
CPOE c'est pour contaminant chimique
comme des métaux P pour les pathogènes
salmonelles et au colis pour éviter une
contamination humaine eau pour l'odeur
et E pour les corps étrangers comme du
verre ou du plastique
les bouts sont échantillonnés par les
entreprises comme englobe qui les
envoient dans des laboratoires
accrédités par le ministère de
l'Environnement et une firme
indépendante fait ses propres contrôles
deux fois par an
[Musique]
le principal inconvénient ça serait les
morceaux de plastique qui sont présents
on envoie un petit peu partout donc
c'est pas majeur parce que on n'a pas
des quantités phénoménales qu'on a je
mettrais pas 100 ans dans un hectare
mais est-ce que à longue ça peut
s'accumuler et causer des problèmes je
pense qu'on va demander un suivi
là-dessus
ce qui explique la présence de plastique
c'est que la Ville de Saint-Hyacinthe
broie les aliments reçus des industries
sans les séparer de leurs emballages il
y a déjà au Québec des technologies qui
sont utilisées pour séparer puis on
travaille justement pour acquérir ces
équipements-là dans le courant des
prochains mois on doit avoir un maximum
de 1% de matière inorganique mais c'est
ce qu'on est toujours en deçà de ces
valeurs là et ce qui fait que justement
on respecte les normes
le ministère ne vérifie pas les
résultats des analyses avant l'épandage
parce que dans plus de 99% des cas les
agronomes n'ont pas demandé
d'autorisation ils doivent seulement
prévenir 10 jours avant donc ça repose
quand même sur une certaine confiance
dans la filière qui déclare que
l'activité qu'il va faire est conforme
aux normes d'encadrement que l'on
prescrit il y a eu 712 inspections
depuis
2017 toute matière fertilisante
confondue donc on a des BIOS solides
mais on a aussi les fumiers par exemple
donc sur ces 712 inspections là on a 205
à ville non conformités près d'une
inspection sur trois révèle une
non-conformité mais comme le ministère
ne fait pas de distinction entre les
matières il n'existe pas d'état des
lieux fiables sur les terres
potentiellement contaminées par des
bouts d'épuration la responsabilité pour
les chantiers de valorisation de matière
résultante je pense que c'est un peu du
cas par cas je dirais mais ultimement
les projets recyclage agricole la
responsabilité nous revient par ailleurs
le guide de référence du ministère date
déjà de 2015 mais en 7 ans plusieurs
études internationales ont conclut qu’il
faut faire plus de contrôle que le CPE
pour s'assurer que les pandages
agricoles de boue ne soient pas
nuisibles pour la santé en ce moment le
fait que l'activité soit encadrée par le
ministère de l'Environnement et
recommandé par des agronomes mais les
agriculteurs ont confiance si le produit
tombait
certainement l'accès à ça nous on a
confiance en se produit là parce que
justement qu'on est prêt si les papiers
on est encadré avec notre agronome les
gens spécialisés chez englobe on n'est
pas à ce niveau là
ça se déroule bien
juste de l'autre côté de la frontière
dans l'état du main le gouvernement a
découvert des centaines de terres
contaminées par des produits chimiques
dit éternels des pfas suite à des
épandages de boue au point dans
l'interdire la pratique l'inquiétude et
généralisée
[Musique]
la voir à l'abandon ça me fait mal
même si on est cultive rien les produits
chimiques restent
ces terres sont désormais contaminées et
les conséquences sont dramatiques pour
les agriculteurs
au Québec le premier guide des bonnes
pratiques entourant les pandage des
bouts d'épuration dans les champs a été
publié dans les années 1980 à la même
époque aux États-Unis dans l'État du
main des agriculteurs commencent à
utiliser ces matières certains le front
pendant des décennies mais aujourd'hui
il le regrette amèrement
[Musique]
nous ne sommes plus que nombre de
nous-mêmes
[Musique]
on fait tourner un énorme système juste
pour traire 4 ou 5 vaches il est conçu
pour entrer 10 ou 20 fois plus
automatisés c'est fini donc oui c'est
pire qu'un accident de train
[Musique]
et producteur laitiers dans le sud du
Maine il a repris la ferme de son
grand-père mais il a tout perdu après
avoir appris que son eau ces terres et
le lait de ses vaches étaient lourdement
contaminés c'est parce qu'entre 1983 et
2004 il a utilisé des résidus pas petit
des cendres et surtout des bouts de deux
stations d'épuration des environs pour
fertiliser ses champs il y fusait
pousser du maïs et du foin pour nourrir
ses vaches ça nous a été présenté comme
fertilisant par l'Agence de protection
de l'environnement et par les stations
d'épuration
tout comme les agriculteurs québécois
fret Stone a été séduit par les
avantages économiques notoires de
l'utilisation des bouts pour remplacer
les engrais
c'était livré ici et on était payé
banque nous payait un montant par berge
pour répandre leur boule dans nos champs
donc c'est gagnant-gagnant
tout a changé le 3 novembre 2016 une
lettre du Service des Eaux de Kenny Bank
informe monsieur Stone que son eau est
fortement pollué par des pfas deux fois
plus que la limite recommandée par
l'agence fédérale de protection de
l'environnement et pfas sont des
molécules synthétiques fabriquées en
laboratoire qu'on retrouve dans de
nombreux produits imperméables comme des
vêtements les poils téflon antiadhésives
les emballages alimentaires anti-graisse
etc ces produits chimiques sont dit
éternel parce qu'il ne se dégradent pas
ou très peu donc on les retrouve partout
dans
parce que l'État ne faisait pas de test
pour ça soit on est formé l'État et
notre laiterie qu'il y avait peut-être
un problème bien sûr on a choisi la
deuxième option qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait
faire d'autre
suite à cette révélation l'État et la
laiterie locale font des analyses dans
l'eau et le lait les résultats sont
éloquents les vaches de Monsieur Stone
produisent du lait qui contient 20 fois
plus de pfas que ce qui était recommandé
dans l'eau potable à l'époque
pourquoi les vaches étaient si
contaminées parce qu'elles buvait de
l'eau contaminée et mangeait de la
nourriture contaminée parce que les sols
sont contaminés
désormais la laiterie locale refuse
d'acheter le lait de la ferme des Stones
après plusieurs mois d'analyse le
gouvernement conclut que la
contamination des sols provient des
épandages de boue pourtant terminer
depuis 2004
dans cette cuve de 4000 litres au lieu
d'être jeté par terre aux égouts
faisaient exactement comme nous partout
dans le même
[Musique]
le département pour la protection de
l'environnement du main un répertorié
plus de 700 sites ayant déjà reçu des
bouts d'épuration municipales ou
industriels depuis plus de 40 ans
[Musique]
qui est apparu l'icône dépendage debout
notaire ont été contaminés par quatre
épandages de bout entre 1991 et 1994
[Musique]
et ponctuel peut avoir un impact si
durable
et Joanna Davis sont agriculteurs
biologiques il cultive ces terres depuis
2014 après avoir appris en 2021 que leur
chance et leur récolte étaient
contaminées ils ont tout arrêté
en une semaine on a contacté nos clients
pour leur dire qu'on avait un problème
et qu'on arrêtait la production ils ont
été incroyablement solidaires les gens
apprécient quand on se tient debout face
aux obstacles
[Musique]
là on aurait dû récolter nos cantaloups
dans quelques semaines cette terre-là
fait pousser des cantalouses sucrés et
délicieux c'est sûr que ça ça manque
comme au Québec il est interdit de
dépendre des bouts sur des cultures
destinées à l'alimentation humaine après
quelques années on peut toutefois
planter des légumes sur ses terres parce
que les pathogènes ont normalement
disparu mais ce n'est pas le cas pour
les contaminants éternels qui persistent
dans le sol l'eau et certains végétaux
pendant des décennies
on voit maintenant les conséquences de
décennie des pandage de ces bouts sur
nos terres des agriculteurs font
faillites sa contamine notaire notre eau
et notre nourriture et ça prend
tellement d'ampleur que c'est désormais
à l'état de Branson en main bile Blokker
est un élu indépendant de la Chambre des
représentants du main et agriculteurs
avant tout c'est ce qu'il a poussé à se
présenter pour défendre les intérêts de
la communauté agricole
j'ai présenté un projet de loi la
Chambre des représentants dans le but de
bannir les pandage des beaux municipal
surtout dans les champs agricoles et
toutes les terres humaines
cette interdiction est entrée en vigueur
tout récemment en août 2022 le main ne
devient alors le premier état à
légiférer sur l'épandage des bouts
d'épuration
ce bannissement résulte des différentes
analyses de pfas réalisées par le
gouvernement à l'échelle de l'Etat dans
les boues le sol l'eau le lait les
bovins et les humains ils s'avère que
toutes les booms municipales et les
composts dérivés de ces bouts
contiennent des pff devant l'ampleur du
phénomène plusieurs producteurs
agricoles s'inquiètent de leur avenir
on a toujours dans l'incertitude on ne
sait pas ce qu'il adviendra de cette
terre comment aller de l'avant trouver
un endroit sécuritaire pour notre enfant
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir déménager
redémarrer notre entreprise
[Musique]
je déteste le mot exterminé mais on a dû
tuer plus de 80% du troupeau les 30 qui
restent proviennent de lignées que je ne
peux pas tuer
cette contamination a aussi des
conséquences sur les agriculteurs chez
qui on retrouve de fortes concentrations
sanguines de pfas
te de 2 mon tout est 111 celui de ma
femme 91 ma fille et mon fils un peu
moins de 5 ans on aura des problèmes de
santé toute notre vie
[Musique]
la médecine de famille Rachel chriswell
reçoit de plus en plus de patients
agriculteurs
les toxicologues ne savent pas
exactement à partir de quelle
concentration sanguine les personnes
exposées au PFS vont avoir des effets
néfastes mais quelques nanogrammes parmi
les litres suffirait
[Musique]
des études épidémiologiques solides ont
montré plusieurs effets sur la santé à
long terme comme des problèmes de
thyroïde de cholestérol des cancers du
rein de la thyroïde et des testicules
dysfonctionnement du foie hypertension
pendant la grossesse durer d'allaitement
écourtée et diminution du poids des
bébés à la naissance
dans quelle mesure ce qu'il se passe au
même doit nous inquiéter ici au Québec
les PFS ne sont pas étudiés en
agriculture Sébastien sauvé professeur
en chimie environnementale à
l'Université de Montréal Alain des rares
laboratoires dans le monde capable de
les analyser
si on veut bien valoriser les biocelyne
au niveau agricole rassurer les
producteurs agricoles qui vont mettre ça
dans leur champ je pense qu'on a pas le
choix de bien caractériser ces produits
là avant le certifié qui sont
sécuritaire en 2016 la santé publique du
Québec avait conclu que cette pratique
ne représentait pas de risques pour la
santé humaine 7 ans plus tard en 2023 le
ministère de l'Environnement analysera
les contaminants potentiels pas étudiées
jusqu'à maintenant dans des bouts de 70
stations de traitement des eaux soit le
pfas ainsi que des résidus de
médicaments des plastiques cosmétiques
perturbateurs endocriniens retardateur
de flammes etc
on est rendu à ce point-là de devoir
remettre un peu à plat par rapport à des
contaminants qui pop un petit peu
partout à travers le monde au niveau de
la conscience scientifique des grands
publics aussi donc de buts de ce projet
de recherche c'est de regarder si on a
une nécessité d'actualiser nos
encadrements puis d'actualiser nos
critères de qualité en ajoutant
peut-être pourquoi pas des nouveaux
contaminants qui seront encadrés
le ministère de l'Environnement a aussi
rejoint un projet de recherche financé
par le Ministère de l'Agriculture et
coordonné par une équipe de l'Université
Laval qui a planté du maïs à ensilage en
juin 2022 2 cent types de matières
résiduelles fertilisantes sont analysées
tout comme les sols et l'eau de
ruissellement les végétaux sont examinés
pour savoir si des contaminants se
retrouvent dans la nourriture des
animaux mais pour l'instant le
gouvernement n'a pas prévu de faire des
échantillons de lait ou de 100 animal ou
humain
quelques mois plus tard à l'automne
c'est l'heure de la récolte
[Musique]
trois épis de maïs et à peu près une
dizaine de feuilles on va voir les
résultats au fur et à mesure qui vont
rentrer et on pourra prendre action au
fur et à mesure qu'on va voir les choses
arriver pour ce qui est des PFL on en
retrouve dans l'eau potable au Québec
mais à des niveaux bien plus bas que
dans le reste du Canada et du monde
Sébastien Sauvet envisage donc en détec
dans les eaux usées les bios solides et
les champs mais dans des quantités
variables selon la source du bio solide
aux États-Unis il y a des usines qui
produisent des pff et aucun site à
travers le Canada qui produit des pfas
il faut valoriser les biocellules au
niveau agricole pour être circulaire
pour réduire notre empreinte
environnementale c'est ce qu'il faut
faire maintenant il faut trouver les
niveaux les seuils sécuritaires pour
tous les contaminants possibles en
fonction des résultats attendus au
printemps le ministère de
l'Environnement aura plusieurs options
ajoutez des critères de qualité au CPE
installer des traitements aux stations
d'épuration légiférer pour diminuer les
contaminants à la source valoriser les
bouts ailleurs qu'en agriculture ou les
enfants
on a fait quand même une
petite
échantillons on va les mettre dans des
pots et on va envoyer ça à nos
différentes plateformes donner les
chimiques donc que ce soit Miguel
l'Université de Montréal où nos
laboratoires à nous au centre
d'expertise
de leur côté les agriculteurs du main
espèrent que leur histoire servira
d'exemple je rêve que notre ferme
devienne une ferme de recherche elle ne
peut plus produire de nourriture
peut-être qu'elle peut produire des
informations
[Musique]
plus vite vous détecter le problème plus
vite vous pourrez vous en occuper
si j'avais su à l'époque ce que je sais
maintenant on aurait pris des décisions
bien différentes
[Musique]
il faut trouver une nouvelle façon de
gérer les bouts de fertiliser nos champs
et d'améliorer le rendement des cultures
pour l'avenir
depuis l'interdiction dépendre du mois
d'août nos collègues de l'émission
Enquête ont découvert que des tonnes de
boue américaines sont détournés pour
différentes utilisations vers le Canada